hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
standards and regulations for animal use
and research challenges and changes in a
chilean university
i am marcel paragentil and i'll be your
moderator
we have a few important announcements
before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit your
questions by typing them in the q a box
which can be found by clicking on the
green q and a button
at the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button
at the top right of your presentation
window or submit your
your problem through the green q and a
button lower left
i would like nothing to introduce today
speaker
and my friend
dr andrea ley sawwitz
dr les edwards is a research ethics
officer at pontifico
a catholic university in chile
she also serves as a biosafety and
biosecurity officer
at the university i will now turn it
over to dr les edwards for her
presentation
uh
thanks marcel
hi everyone i'm andrea
and i'm the current research ethics and
security officer of the pontificia
universia catolica in chile in south
america
so first of all i would like to thank
marcel and all the organizers for
inviting me to share with you our
experience in um
in trying to
do things right here in chile especially
in our institution so what i'm going to
talk today and show to you is how in
just a couple of years
a couple of years we we changed
the whole research ethics system within
the university and especially for
animals and animal
care
um
so first of all um i'm gonna start with
uh telling you about our regulatory
context our legislation um and a little
bit of history and you will see that
it's very recent um
then i'm going to talk about what was
really happening in reality uh
compared to what is supposed to be
happening
then some events that we got uh here in
chile and at our institution and then
the new model that we are implementing
um
in our university
so i'm gonna start with
what was our regulatory context um
so um as you can see here
our legislation is very recent
our legislation regarding research
ethics so it was just in 1999 early
2000s that we got uh the law 19
628 that is about protection of private
life this this regulations talk about um
what kind of data is private what kind
of data is not private uh then five
years later uh
we well we adhere to the unesco uh
declaration so uh in 2005
it was this uh universal declaration on
bioethics and human rights uh
uh of unesco
and it was in the same year where um our
main
funding agency fundes it um
built up an advisory board uh on
research ethics or in bioethics so it
was 2005 just in 2005 where like our our
nih like funding agency um decided to
take care about uh rich research ethics
in our country
so uh it was the
the next year in 2006 where the law
twenty thousand one twenty about
scientific research in human beings and
its genome and prohibits human cloning
that's the name of the law uh that came
up
but in chile things are kind of special
and we need a regulation act
where it's an act that states how to
implement different laws so as you can
see
the
regulation act from
uh from this law in 2006 just came up in
2011
late 2011 early 2000s 2012.
so it it was just six years later that
this this law started to be applied and
that that was the main issue
it was just two or three years ago just
very recent
in 2009 we got this law the twenty
thousand three eighty about animal
protection and that's this is our first
law that talks a little bit not all of
the law but just there it has a part
about animal experimentation and it was
in 2009
so uh what does this law says
um
this law recognizes animals as living
beings capable to feel and that are
subject to receive adequate treatment
avoiding unnecessary suffering
i highlighted unnecessary suffering
because this is the main
contribution of this law
in my in my opinion
um
this law has a focus on education
and in on responsible pet ownership so
the main focus of this law is to teach
or the community to be responsible with
their pets and not it doesn't care very
much about animal experiment or
experimentation with animals
it defines experiment in leaf animals as
any use in order to test a scientific
hypothesis try a natural or synthetic
product
producing medical or biological
substances of use detect phenomena
materials or effect making teaching
demonstrations perform operations and in
general study and know their behavior
that's the definition of experiment in
the animals it's very broad
this law also says that the experiments
on living animals may only be performed
by qualified personnel
but it doesn't say
what does it mean qualified personnel
um
also it says that the
it is required the use of anesthesia to
avoid unnecessary suffering in surgeries
and that procedures must be performed by
a veterinarian or other qualified
professional that is again not defined
what is a
qualified professional
um
then it says that such experiments must
be practices must be practiced in
appropriate facilities that is again not
defined what is an appropriate facility
we can imagine that it's a i don't know
an operate an
operation room or pursue room
but it's not specified
and
the permission
uh to conduct such such experiments must
be granted by the high school principal
if it is uh performing a
in a school
or the dean of the respective faculty if
it is in a university
and finally requires the use of rational
methods for animal sacrifice aimed at
causing unnecessary distress that is not
defined it is not defined what is a
rational method for animal sacrifice so
um
there are
some key concepts in this law regarding
animal um experimentation
um the law is longer and it covers other
items regarding um
education teaching in
responsible ownership of animals but
regarding animal experimentation it says
unnecessary suffering uh
something that is very important is that
the owner's responsibility the animals
are the owners responsible
the owners are responsible for their
animals and if we extrapolate to
researchers i would say that the
researchers the investigators are
responsible of the animals that they
keep in
animal facility
it mentions qualified personnel
appropriate facilities and rational
methods for animal sacrifice and at the
end of the law it is stated that the
regulation act will grant guidelines and
mechanisms to implement this law
but it's february 2015 and still we
don't have any regulation act supposedly
and as the law stated
it was
it stated that six months after um
after the law enactment uh
a board should have been constituted to
um
to develop or to um
to develop this regulation act or to
state the guidelines that we need but it
is february 2015
and we still don't have any
uh regulation act so
as our chilean as i was saying are
chilean culture so we need a regulation
act to implement laws um
nobody's implementing anything regarding
animal experimentation because we don't
have regulation act
in general terms
okay so
how was or how is the status of ayacox
or research ethics committees or irbs in
general in chile
as i said in 2005
the main funding agency that is a
governmental funding agency pharmacy
it's like our nih um
and
so it was uh created this bioethic
advisory board that the main goal was to
check all the bioethics or the ethical
considerations uh in their proposal that
they were funding
um
so uh that made
that made the institutions or the
research institutions as universities uh
to have their own
research ethics board or research ethics
committees to review the proposals that
we're going to apply to grants funded by
phantasy but this but this
agency uh
also uh in the
what was required starting 2006 um
to apply to these grants was the
was
that institutional research ethics
committee should review and approve
uh new proposals that will
apply to pharmacies uh uh
grants
so uh that made um
then within 2005 and 2006
uh most of research ethics committees
were uh funded or were created within
research uh research institutions or
universities so
in in our institution in particular um
the school of medicine was concerned
before
2005 regarding um
ethical approval of protocols that were
using um
human subjects or or patients
so
the
the
the irb or the research ethics committee
or research ethic committee regarding
human subjects in the school of medicine
was created before 2005 but that was one
of the only one uh examples
of of of of
of um creation of
of comedies before the law or their
pharmacists requirements but the main
the main ethics committees came up
within
um
in 2005 the end of 2005 and 2006.
so what was the need what
what uh these committees were why these
committees were created so fundus this
main funding agency
started to request for the application
purposes a document indicating that the
researchers
um
that the the researcher that is applying
requested the ethical revision of its
proposal
so at the beginning
at the beginning of the application so
fund is it
um
receives these documents uh this
document is like a letter uh
saying that the researcher uh presented
all the documentation to the research
ethic committee so it will be
after 90 days approximately
the researcher has to submit the
approval uh
the ethical approval to fund the city
that is before the resolution that is
before the grand uh
the grand um
results right the application results
um
and then um
researchers need
the need was that they re that
it was required
to show these documents so researchers
need a research ethic committees
uh or a research ethic committee that
gives them the documentation they need
to apply to these grants right to this
um funding agency
so
well so in chile
there was no
culture about what a research ethic
committee should do
so the result of this
request by fundacity was that
uh it was a reactive solution right
so
a lot of committees were created
everywhere so there were no guidelines
nobody cared about
regulations or guidelines they just
they just wanted to support researchers
in the grant application process
so it was kind of disorganized
everywhere um
anyway so that was the result and
as an example in our institution in the
participation here catholica that is one
of the main research institutions in
chile
so we have 18 schools and
until
last year uh middle of
2014
uh there were
24 research ethics committees
constituted
responding to this need or to this
necessity of researchers to have support
for their uh grant application process
um
about 120 faculty members working in one
of these committees um
most of them but not all of them uh but
most of them were not aware as i said
about the national regis
legislation or international guidelines
so uh
so all the requirements all the
processes were
very you know
variable
among these 24 committees
so uh the committee members in general
were working about
eight hours per month
uh in average uh
of course
during the period of time that is there
was grant application you know weeks so
they were working more and there were
periods of the year that they didn't
meet
um
in in average they were working about
eight to ten hours uh per month per
member of the these research ethic
committees
it was extra work uh and no support so
uh it was something that it was um
so
it was something that that
a group of faculty members decided to do
this kind of work to review the ethical
aspect of the proposals
because the researchers needed that for
their application process
so because we had a lot of members and
with different backgrounds and different
at different schools and with different
requirements so all the requirements the
ethical requirements or the ethical
consideration that they took that they
considered to approve or not
the proposal
was very variable and not established
not
so there was no continuity in
one year after the other year so
you know
it was very messy that that's the
message
um and of course it was not according uh
to the national legislation because they
didn't know about the national
national legislation
uh
regarding the management it was
practically non-existent they were not
not policies internal policies uh no
training not even training for the um
research ethic committees members uh
there were a lot of conflict of interest
there were deans uh uh being the
chair of the research ethic committee
and of course the dean wanted more
uh proposals to be applied
to get more money uh more funding and
and of course
you know
we can think that there were a lot of
conflict of interest um
within these committees um
there were no regular meetings they were
meeting
just by necessity etc
so the problem uh was high workload no
motivation of of the committee members
no researchers trained they didn't care
about training researchers regarding the
ethical aspects of the
proposals um
of course with it was a high member
change every year they were changing
committee members and that was you know
not
that that that was again that went
against the continuity of of the of the
comedy
uh and of course it was a lot it was
considered as a bureaucratic uh or
bureaucracy
anyway so how was this this is very
global all research ethic committees
human animals etc so how was the status
of the
um
research ethic comedies in
animal care and use
so in our institution there were four
schools the faculty of biological
science school of medicine faculty of
chemistry and faculty of agronomy each
of them had one animal care and use
comedy
the main the main ones were from the
faculty of biological science and the
school of medicine they were reviewing
about
150 protocols the faculty of biological
science and
around 60 or 70 um protocols at the
school of medicine at the faculty of
chemistry and faculty of agronomy they
were reviewing about five or six a year
protocols a year
anyway these four
animal care and used communities had
different composition
different
protocols and different documentation
they requested different kind of
uh documentation they requested
different uh information within these
documents uh
so the it was very variable what the
requirements were to approve a protocol
and they had different criteria to
evaluate them of course
so i i was part at that time i was part
of the school of medicine and i was part
of the
committee uh that is the ethics and
animal welfare committee at the school
of medicine seba in its um spanish um
uh that's this is from
in
uh
so
here i show um
how many new proposals we were uh
reviewing so this this comedy was funded
in 2008 uh not in 2005 or six like the
others the the committee of the faculty
of biological science was funded in 2006
this is two years later um
so
this year so we started reviewing about
30 or 40 protocols a year and we end up
2014 reviewing about 70 particles um
and it was
in 2012
that something changed um within the
requirements of our my main funding
agency foundacy so fundacity uh aligned
with the national legislation uh started
to require protocol follow-up um
at least once during the the
the time that the protocol is active or
the the funding is active
um
it started to require site dates visits
and reports so
in reports by the institutional research
ethic committee or by the seva or the
committee that was in charge at the
moment so
uh
this year was a year that that
you know things got complicated for the
for our system because
uh it was for the committees it was okay
to support their uh their researchers
and approve their protocol so they get
can apply to more funding but now uh the
same committees
had to do these protocol follow-ups and
make some reports and submit them to the
funding agency
and that was a major major issue in our
our culture and our institutions so
people didn't like it
it was complicated
so uh and then
we
as the committee at school of medicine
that was uh in
taking care of the the animal protocols
we started to
uh to change our
our criteria
we started to
to study international guidelines that
was a little bit before of course that
the year before the end of 2010 and
beginning of
2011 because we knew that it was this
was coming and we knew that we needed to
work more and and we needed to
to do this uh
right
so we started to compare um
in our follow-ups or our site visit we
started to compare what researchers
indicated in the protocol that we
approved uh
with what they were actually doing so we
found a lot of inconsistency of course
so they promised something in their
documentation but they were doing
different things in reality so that was
um an opportunity to teach them and to
and to educate them in good practices in
in in
you know so if if you promise something
if you decided to use this anesthesia
you should use that anesthesia if you
are going to change the drug so just ask
the committee and you need approval etc
so we started we started educating a lot
um
our researchers again this is just the
school of medicine our university is
bigger than that but at least we were
working on that
um
a
a very important person was hired at the
school of medicine that is that that's
uh jessica gimpel that is a veterinarian
she has a phd in animal welfare from
oxford and she was uh crucial to develop
all these new um
way
of doing things uh so it was
the same time the end of 2011 beginning
of 2012.
but of course this meant a high workload
for our committee
uh but we understood that our role as co
as the animal welfare committee was of
highest importance so
uh we wanted to do things right and
educate our researchers in good
practices so that was
you know our main goal and and and
and we decided to take that challenge
so
um
our our committee was as i said was
funded in 2009 uh
in 2008
was funded it started uh in
in reality started working in 2009 and
our first main goal was of course as of
any other research ethic committees to
support
our researchers in the application
process but then we we moved and we
understood understood as i said uh that
we wanted uh that this was of highest
importance and and we took that as a
challenge
so it was in 2012 at the same time that
we started to do these site visits um
that the chair that was me at the time
um that the chair uh requested a
protected time to dedicate uh to the
committee so i was a
researcher had my own lab i was doing i
had some funding proposals i was
teaching and this was extra work but i
understood that it was of highest
importance and with jessica's support so
i went uh to my dean and i asked for
protected time and and he understood and
he understood that this was of highest
importance so he gave me the protected
timing that was
amazing because it was you know
something that we didn't expect
of another another uh event that we had
in 2012 was an activism event it was
very violent
and it was um
something that uh
changed our
uh dean's view of what
research ethics and how to deal with um
animal activism uh so he understood that
and and he it was together with you know
this protected time and to understand
that that we needed uh we needed support
uh to do things right and to protect our
researchers and to do research right and
to show the world and especially
the activists that we try to keep our
you know our um
our animal experience within you know
certain limits and using the three r's
and and trying to to avoid unnecessary
suffering etc
so what happened that was in our
our own institution the pontificion
catholic but what happened at the
national level
we decided to uh
to check what it was happening in other
research institutions so we
made a survey that we got about 18
answers so
uh we have more than 18 uh research
institutions but it was okay so what we
did we were very careful we submitted a
uh one-to-one
email so knowing people because we know
that activism is getting
animal activism is getting really strong
here in chile so we were very careful we
got 18 answers uh
and uh
most of them most of the research
institution had a committee a research
ethic committee regarding animal caring
use
um
the answers were
variable when we asked if if the
dependency of a committee was by faculty
or by school or at the institutional
level so
it wasn't clear most of them believed
that it was institutional but
not very sure so but at least most of
the research institutions had uh um
and research ethic committees or an kind
of ayakook
and this answer when we asked about
meeting frequency it was very
interesting because most of them
were meeting by necessity
i i mean uh when they get a lot of
protocols they need if they don't get
any protocol they don't meet um
and that that goes against um you know
continuity and and
again goes against what a committee
should do
in times of low work when when
they have time to establish criteria to
develop
procedures and manuals and guidelines
but anyway so that that it wasn't very
different as in our institution at that
time so
so in general it was not only us so
every research institution had the same
kind of structure
i'm not showing all the data if you want
the survey data i can share it with you
but um
most of them had the same structure most
of them were faculty members with no
training
with no experience but just trying to
support you know researching their
institution they have the same problems
most of them didn't have any
authority support so no money to
to to to work or to for the meetings or
so it was very you know
uh
you know a group of
faculty members i wanted to help others
that that was that was that's the same
the same thing that we had
so we decided after that to do this the
first laboratory animal care and use
committee meeting we decided to meet
with all of them
and that happened in july 2013
the main goals were of course to meet to
know each other and to establish a
network so we can share our experiences
our
documents our guidelines or you know
anything to support each other
uh
another main goal was to unify some
basic revision
criteria we invited to this uh to this
uh meeting uh people from
uh the phantasy program from our nih the
main funding agency and they were very
delighted to hear that we wanted to
make a proposal to
the country right through fund assets
through this um main agency regarding
what the guidelines should all the
criteria should be to uh review animal
protocol rm experimentation protocols
and of course establish some agreements
that was uh
uh one of the main goals so what we did
was uh and in the end we wanted to do
this uh to do a document to to send uh
to send out to to the main funding
agency from the city
um
so we did presentations we did
discussion groups and we we
we agree in some
some
things uh we decided to to
so we established the the network we
have the network that is named red
ciguales um
and um
and then we decided to make up one
national
protocol one national document where uh
the researchers should fill up and and
then submit to
their own ayakook or research ethics
committees committee um we are working
on this document um and we decided to
follow the guide for for the care and
use of
laboratory animals of an nrc um this
standard so
you know it was very very nice it was a
three-day meeting
um and i think it was very fruitful and
now um
we are going to have the second
laboratory animal meeting um
care and use committee uh in august this
year so we'll see and and we will see
what you know
what's the status of the other aya cooks
um
so uh again um
coming back to this we had this activism
event
and
we had uh we had at the same time we
needed to do this protocol follow-up in
2000 starting 2012.
and and when this happened
we as a comedy as a committee from the
school of medicine
um
we went to the dean and we asked
if we have as a
school of medicine or as a uni
university as an institution if we have
an emergency plan against activism
events um
and and
nobody knew at that moment
um and then uh we went
uh to the vice presidents for research
uh at that moment to ask them that's the
advice the
person that is in charge of the whole
research
areas in the university not by faculty
but at the university level and he
didn't know at that time uh what to do
in case of of activism events
um
he said okay um
so
we don't we don't have any emergency
plan but the one that should know about
that is the vice president of for
communications of the university
so we went there and we came up with an
emergency plan because there was no
emergency plan against activism so that
was a big big issue and that was
nice to
to to to have now so um it took about a
year to get that so that was that was a
high improvement and the other issue
that the vice president for research
commented us at that time this is the
end of 2012
if it was how
were the research ethic committees by
school were planning to do the protocol
follow-ups
and and he asked us
to
unify
the four
uh research ethic committees in animal
or animal welfare committees
from these four schools in one and he
requested us to guide or to be the
leaders in this unification or union you
know making one comedy um
so we started working in unified unified
them all and we came up with this
proposed work plan so first of all we
had to define what what is going to be
the composition of the comedy to recruit
committee members to define procedures
we decided to work of course
under the guidance of the guide uh the
nrc guide uh defined attributions and
duties of the committee members are
training etc etc
and it was at the same time that was the
end of 2012
uh that we were working in unified then
all the animal care and use committees
within the university uh leading by the
school of medicine
and and
apparently university was more concerned
that uh they
they said and and he opened up a new
position at the end of december 2012.
and he were requesting requesting
someone to take care of the whole
research ethics and security uh of the
university an institutional research
ethics and security officer position
so
um
so they were concerned about issue about
issues regarding research ethics in
general
irb ayako security not only animals but
also um
also um
human rights or research with human
subjects
so i applied and i got the position and
that that's why under the institutional
research ethics and security officer
right now but um
but again i i think it was because we
were we as a
seva was a committee within the school
of medicine decided to take this
challenge as a kind of personal
challenge or kind of highest importance
uh challenge so
probably that's why we
i'm here right
so
um at the beginning of 2013
uh their research ethics and security
office was created i was the only member
of that office um now we are more but
more people working here but um our main
goal um
as an office an office was to ensure
research ethics and integrity
from the conception of the proposal
until the end of its execution through
develop through the development of
policies promoting good scientific
practices and supporting the work of the
research ethic committees
and establishing together with these
committees training instances
on ethics integrity and security of
research um for members of the
universities community of all
people that need uh training in these
areas
so uh
the first thing that we needed to do was
to develop develop policies uh
institutional policies regarding
research ethics
so it was in
last july
2014 that uh
the new regulation and the new policy
came up we worked about a year and a
half in this policy and and it was
approved uh in in july 2014 um
and uh these policies created institute
created created ah creators
institutional research ethic committees
establish
it establish uh functions and mechanism
how to do uh
how to implement the functions right uh
how
the committees can can can do
they have to review they have to do
follow-ups they have to uh submit uh
reports etc
also it defines what is what research
means for us as an institution as that
as a pontificioners
of course according to national
legislation and international guidelines
but also because we are catholic we have
some you know other other regulations
that apply uh that apply to us
uh
it established committees researchers
and institutions responsibilities and
that's very important so what are the
responsibilities of a researcher of the
committee and
what uh are the responsibility of the
institution uh establishes uh training
as a requirement so
now on all our researchers must do some
training in research ethics integrity
and security
uh and if our researchers are going to
work with animals they will
they will need to show their training in
research uh
with animals or in in animal you know
handling and stuff
so and also it established the function
of our office um
so
so now we have so this is our university
and now we have three
we created three
major uh three um research ethic
committees we have one in biomedical
science another one is social behavioral
um
art and humanities
and the third one is in animal care and
use
uh and also we created a security
committee and and why we don't call them
biosecurity is because we have some
security issues um
in all of three uh
research
main fields right and we need to take
care and to educate our people um
in security like uh risks risk
prevention that i don't know how to say
that but
um
and also biosecurity so we cover more
than just buying security and this
committee uh is an advisory committee
that uh bring risk management thanks um
so this committee um
elaborates um
reports to each research ethic committee
regarding the particular proposal and
and is the
the research ethic committee the irb or
the ayaku the one that decides to
approve or not uh the proposal uh
uh taking consideration our evaluation
of security or security evaluation
so the next the next uh goal is to
establish training instances um in
ethics integrity and security
so we are developing now so
the committees were just um
created or the members were recruited
last november so three months ago uh and
now our goal is to us is to develop some
um
training instances for our graduate
students for our uh community
committee members and the rest of
researchers and faculty members and also
that's our first goal and there are
second probably uh in another in a year
or so we will develop some training
instances
to other
kind of
people like uh clinicians um and
undergrad students but our main goal is
to to educate our researchers
and we we um
we got the city program the one the the
collaborative initiative of training
of the university of miami that has a
lot of
information that is very useful for us
of course and i know that it's very
useful for everybody so we are
developing um some profiles that are
you know trying to um
in to include some information regarding
our national reality like our like our
legislation and other issues that are
particular to our country um
but of course
you know
this training instance is very useful
for us it has a lot of information and i
i think it will be great for the
beginning
to start with um
but also we need we feel that it's very
important to have on-site uh
um
you know
case analysis talks and debates that
should be on site especially for our
grad to students because it will
exemplify what they read uh in the city
program right what they you know all the
contents to to put in a more applied
example and that probably that will that
will help them to understand all the
ethical considerations in every area not
only animal animal care and use but of
course in every you know
in in
human subject etc
and um
so are what so i i just mentioned that
our ayakook uh
was uh confirmed in
last november
and you know this is the composition we
have an external member
we have a certified veterinarian we have
a lawyer we need that we feel that it's
very important to have a lawyer in our
committees especially in ayaku because
um
you know with all the activism that is
going on and and we you know we need as
an institution that we can we can
propose a lot of um
guidelines to the rest of our country um
because we are a big university
there are instances that we can go and
and propose to the government some
changes maybe help in the development of
the regulation act
from our law regarding animals
protection etc so so we need a lawyer
and and it's very important i think for
every you know irb or iacock
so we have researchers that work with
laboratory animals researchers that work
with
big animals like cows and and
you know other big animals
we have
other kind of researchers uh such as
statisticians
we feel that it's very important uh to
have a statistician in our ayakook
because
of the
reduce you know they are
uh to reduce and to justify how many
animals do you need to to do or to
to submit to a procedure to get a
reliable data and and that will help us
to reduce a lot of our numbers um
and we that's a major another you know
big thing is that we have a full-time uh
assistant that is a veterinarian that is
in charge of the management of the
committee but also as a committee member
and she she's uh she's hired full-time
and she helps a lot so having people uh
with protected time or
full-time people working in the
committee helps a lot and especially in
an institution that is very big
so the effects of the this new policy is
that all the
24 research ethic committees the local
wrecks disappeared
just now in december 2014.
uh three institutional research ethic
committees were created um
we we
hope
that these three are enough to review
all the research protocols um
of our university but maybe it won't so
it you know this is like this year will
be a testing year
um
of course we
are trying to be aligned with the
national legislation and international
guidelines um we have a centralized
management
and um
and responsibility of research ethics
integrity and security that's very good
i'm i'm full-time here now and and we
are trying to develop you know this
cultural change we have to change a lot
of you know old researchers that were
used to do things in another way so you
know it will be a lot of work but it's
very challenging but it's very you know
gratifying that we are trying to do
things right
um we are facing of course a big big big
big challenge and so we have just you
know to give you a like
how big is our institution
we have about 23 000 undergrad students
about 3 000 masters students
about a thousand phd students and
approximately 5 000 faculty members that
do research and that have research
protocols and that apply to you know
fundacity funding to learn you know
so it's a lot a lot of work and we
expect about 2500 new proposals this
year and probably uh it will be more but
that's what we expect so hopefully
so i'm not sure if you know
it's too much but
but anyway
so um
some conclusions of this it was a
reactive solution but i guess we are in
the right way uh the main advantage that
we had is that people that detected the
needs and the problems and look for a
solution
um as a challenge and opportunity it's a
challenge an opportunity to do things
better
we knocked at every door we exposed the
authorities you know the problems the
need the importance of this and they
supported us and that's you know the
major
change here and that was a major sign
for us uh
that we're in the right way and we you
know and and we had the support and they
gave us resources and and so it's a you
know institutional commitment now that's
that's awesome
anyway so
we expect for ayaku about 500 new
proposals about 200 uh research projects
that will require follow-up this year
and about
you know 50 phd students that will need
training in animal welfare and animal
hunting so probably we'll have our i
will have a lot of work and wish me luck
because i don't have any results here
yet so probably next year i can talk to
you about uh results so
thank you um and
thanks again to the organizers uh for
giving me the opportunity to show you
how you know in south america in chile
that is you know
a fairly organized country um
things are very way behind as other
countries in terms of research ethics
but we are trying to you know catch up
so thanks and i will get any answers um
let me do this
well thank you andrea for the good
presentation and i was aware of some of
the issues in chile
and but you went in depth and that was
good for me to know
wow you have a lot ahead of you but
you've made incredible progress and i
know because i've we've spoken before
and
well congratulate you and commend you
for such admirable work
so before we get started on the q a
session i would like to remind you
that
how to submit your questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the q
a box which can be found by clicking on
the green q a button
on the lower left of the presentation
window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
and let's see
what our first question is
okay our first question comes from maria
andres from cellular and molecular
biology
don't you think
that to ask for approval for any change
in the protocol will slow
the speed of research and it will
increase enormously the work of the
committee isn't it better to have a
standard
to have standard protocols approved in
advance
yeah thanks um
thanks for that question um
so uh there are things that
that um
so any change in the protocol
it would mean
minor or big change if you want to
change like the the i mean the number of
animals that you need uh and you
increase the number for example from 10
to 100 you should justify and that
should be reviewed by the by the by the
full committee
there are minor changes that maybe will
have expedited revision and won't won't
slow down that um
that
the the speed of research as you say um
we are working have standard protocols
we're working also in a manual to have
like standardized procedures that will
be approved if you just mentioned that
uh
that that
particular procedure uh to speed up of
course the the research and the
approvals um
we're working so it's a big challenge
we're working in a lot of things at the
same time of course uh
uh any suggestion it will be welcomed um
but yeah so we we we're trying to
to to to do things right and we are
trying to to
to help researchers uh
in every every every step of this
okay the next question comes from
jennifer henry
mcgill mcgill university
what type of training do you require do
you provide that training is it
theoretical
or
and or practical
so um
so what we
we are going to request is training in
research ethics in general like ethical
considerations of research ethic
protocols or of in
research protocols in general
uh regarding animal animal use we need
at least a you know
a like a theoretical background
regarding you know three r's and other
principles uh that would guide this
the researchers in their design
but also if if there are some um
specific procedures
we
will require some training some training
like practical training in some specific
procedures if they are complicated but
what we do what we are doing now is um
usually some researchers or some faculty
members they know how to do some
procedures and if their students go and
they're trained them it's okay we we
still don't need a certification like a
formal certification as a university
we're going to
implement some certified training like
handling and practical practical
instances
but we have
like two or three years to implement
that so
that's another step
we're trying to but we will it will be
required some handling and practical and
theoretical um
training
this question and this question comes
from edgar globos universidad dr jaci
jose matthias delgado
many thanks for sharing your valuable
experience for establishing a proper
framework
of regulation for research involving
animals the chilean situation is somehow
surprising given the importance of
biomedical research or chile's economy
but parallels the situation in many
latin american countries
what do you think is needed to implement
the recently passed
chilean laws
and
how could one improve the governance
for checking that the law is implemented
well that's a big question um if i
understood well um
so
the regulation act it will be very
important um there are some some new
it will be very important if it comes up
uh soon because it will give us um
you know the framework how to start
application applicating the law uh
like
about a year ago
a regulation arc
came
for the big animals like the the
how do you call this sag
so it's a governmental institution that
take care of big animals like um
like uh food animals like cows and meat
you know to produce the the
you know
chickens and stuff to to eat
um
and
last year became a regulation act
regarding
how to
uh handle them
also this institution that is a
governmental institution make some
research in animals and and the
regulation act just for them for this
institution uh because this government
that they have a particular regulation
act um
stated that um they were going to follow
basically the guide right it wasn't
stated like that but the principles that
were follow that
they decided to follow were you know the
three r's and and
and you know all the principles that
that you know are like universal
principles um and now that that is a big
you know in a major sign so probably if
a regulation act
comes for
our law
uh
about animal protection
it will follow of course the
international guidelines and it will
follow i'm sure uh the the you know
the the guide um i hope so
uh
that's one thing so we need the
regulation ad so legally we we need you
know we need
for us as a culture we need something
that say okay you should start applying
this but another thing is that training
or education we need to to change
people's mind here in our country and to
show them that that you know this is
important and and that we need
we need to follow
the
the guidelines it's not because we want
to and because you know i just decided
to do it but it has you know a sense it
makes sense to you know be responsible
to do things right i i hope i i answer
your question but but i i think it's
you know
uh we need two things you know so
you know the regulation act and some you
know socialize and educate in good
practices you know the whole country not
not only in our institution locally
the next question is for maria undress
cellular and molecular biology what do
you think would be the acceptable form
for long experienced
researchers to demonstrate their
proficiency to work with animals
so i think um
so there are there are researchers that
we know that they have a lot of
experience that they were trained abroad
or they have a lot of work done uh they
have published a lot of work in terms of
so
for long experienced researchers so i
believe that
will be
um
enough maybe to
to to show you know how they work and
how
how or where they were trained
um because we know that that that like
um
you know looks long experience as you
say uh researchers they it would be very
hard to
to make them
uh
do the you know the online training or
the practical training maybe the
practical is not
it's it won't be necessary unless it's a
very as a new
pro a new i don't know technique that is
not it was not implemented before in
their labs
but maybe you know some some particular
you know concepts like theoretical maybe
basic
i think they will it would be nice to
the this this research just to to
refresh some you know concepts
and jennifer henry had another question
how did you get a statistician to
participate do they get paid as a
committee member
no um
so
at the school of medicine uh it was this
statistician that was working before in
our committee in us in the seva
and and he was he's hired by the school
of medicine to help
the researchers in the
research design and you know the groups
and how how much samples do they need
etc in different areas not only animals
and and we at some point about two years
ago we
we asked him to be part of the seva
i was i think it was in 2013
um or 2000 and at the end of 2012 and he
was happy to participate uh as a faculty
member of the school of medicine so he
doesn't get paid he's very
he's he's very helpful in in the design
of the experiment the you know the
research uh design
also um when we started recruiting um
faculty members
uh to come to compose our ayako
uh
the dean of agronomy proposed us a
particular faculty member that he's uh
from the agronom he does some research
in a you know the agronomical or
agricultural field
but he
had um
a specialization in statistics and
methodology and he's another one he's
not a statistician but he's another you
know very helpful person that knows a
lot about you know uh statistics and and
you know group assignment
group design and you know everything so
so
it was we were lucky i guess yeah
yeah
yeah
okay we uh i think we're running out of
time i'd just like to
state a mention coming the rubber gun
from fda
stated robert stated that
it's not a question but
places in the u.s are facing the same
issues so good luck
and so that concludes this session and i
think we had a couple of uh questions
that were not answered and feel free to
ask those questions offline directly to
andrea
and but i want to thank the audience for
their
great questions and and the
participation in today's event
uh know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
august 2015 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay
we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event so we'll
see you next time and goodbye and thank
you andrea again that was a great great
presentation
and we admire what you're doing